so how would how would we create a more
sex positive culture
I think by educating ourselves a lot
more about it like I think that we need
to really get into this whole thing of
energy it matters you know every person
how should we educate so if you're gonna
are you gonna educate kids are you going
to educate teenagers when do we start
the education yeah I think we should
start the education in schools because
it's normal okay
[Music]
um I think when puberty starts so like
13 forecast yeah it's about 14 years old
how do you educate do you tell them how
to have sex no I think you should tell
them about the feeling it's a guide yeah
no I think we should tell them about the
feelings that they're going to
experience you know um